hello reject nation Greg Alva here I'm
John
so from Marvel Entertainment they
uploaded a video not long ago cloak and
dagger sneak peek exclusively on
freeform John yeah yeah Marvel new
marvel marvel marvel marvel marvel
server the marvel marvel marvel
[Music]
I'm sorry I had a day and it's possible
I started this party too early food the
ruined no to be told I never wear this
thing probably use a little more high
school experience on it hey you should
wear it more often things nicely off
your shoulders Thanks
what's your name Tandy did you know my
dad named me after his first computer I
did not hand a god how about you yeah
yeah your names are cloak and dagger
yeah so I'm gonna go get some proper
cows something a little more absorbing
sorbets yes hey Lord geez
hey yeah hey hold power fine my girl
yeah that was fun I got five bucks a cup
yeah please drink it
what's wrong my wallet she jacked it
oh hey blonde girl
[Music]
that's a nice reversal yeah
like some cool like sy5 type of music
synth
[Music]
hours
[Music]
No
[Music]
dang you're good yeah it's a pretty cool
scene to show bumping into each other
for the first time draw you into the
start of their little relationship yeah
yeah I've been watching Marvel's
Runaways lately I stopped because we
started with TV show reactions very good
I should probably do the last couple
over here but this seems in tune with a
new phase of Marvel what they're doing
with television coz Runaways is uh they
have the adult story in there but they
also have this teenage drama story and
it's really hone in on the teen drama
tale and this seems to have that essence
to like the first couple minutes of this
clip is just a very slow-moving tone
really taking its time with its scene
and getting to know you moment so I like
that this show is really taking its time
it's slowed down and you could already
tell from the vibes that these people
probably have some tough backgrounds I
like what Marvel is doing with this you
know tough teenager background and then
they discover they have powers you know
yeah I think that's a really cool avenue
for them to explore partly just because
it makes the landscape more diverse you
know you're telling different kinds of
stories and things like that yeah and I
like that they're headed that direction
with their newer and new media types
yeah they've got a show on Hulu they've
got show on freeform and each one seems
to come with its own tone and own
approach this seems like a hybrid of the
Netflix tones and the runaway tone this
seems like a solid hybrid between the
two for sure and I mean it looks like
every element is gonna be compelling
they took time to have a nice scene play
out you know and they had even a subtle
twist at the end of that scene that led
right into a more action-oriented stuff
and it made me excited to see not only
them get to know each other but also
what their powers are gonna be attic
together because I'm not that familiar
with cloak and dagger or know these
serials to fall in love with each other
which is nice interracial love like us
like us we're interracial yeah I did
think it was a nice scene because the
way it plays out you do think oh it's
just a chemistry romance scene and I
like that I was really taking its time
it didn't feel rushed at all and they
both had kind of have this depressed the
meaner about
so you're like oh they're bonding they
kind of got this dark thing and then
their background so they're not
specifically laying out but you could
tell by their vibe that they're bonding
so that was a nice switch where oh she's
actually a thief and she just
pickpocketed him yeah did they bond or
did she just take him for a ride off
they're both it's both obviously wants
me to ask the clip assumes that I need
to be coerced into watching the show and
that's the question well I hope this
shows good Marvel is usually a hit when
it comes to I don't mean just in terms
of ratings but in terms a quality
content yeah I really do a pretty good
job I said usually underline that word
italicize and bolded microsoft word that
word count
control-z just take how many episodes
are in the defenders and however many
episodes are in iron fist and ask
yourself well are you guys excited for
it comment below and tell us if you
subscribe to free four because I don't
know anyone who does they're got a lot
of shows though too many a lot of ads
for free form shams and I'm like where
do I watch them I don't know I don't
know guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
make sure to follow us on patreon guys
do full-length TV show reactions on
there right now I don't even react to
this one might even react to this just
got to pay for a subscription service to
free form yeah I don't know what form of
payment do they require yourself free
form if we have to pay I'm gonna do some
research and get back to you I'm going
to do that every mmediately stop
everything we're doing the next video is
actually gonna be just me explaining
it's a style of improv